Okay,
so the question is can that sense of
meaning behind jacked and the answer to
that is absolutely,
absolutely,
because you could say that the ultimate
sense of meaning is composed of the
Union of fragmentary senses,
of meaning and the fragmentary sensitive
meaning can be overwhelmingly powerful,
anger,
sexual lust and and,
and the sorts of things that you
experienced wouldn't say when you're
playing a video game which are very
carefully calibrated to keep you on the,
on the edge of exploration.
Let's say now I'm not a full of video
games because games are complicated and
it isn't clear what people are doing
when they're playing them,
you know,
they may be expanding their cognitive
skills,
they may be learning to cooperate,
they may be learning to engage in
complex problem solving and so,
but part of it's also a matter of
balance,
you know,
50 hours a week,
probably not,
unless you're going to go pro,
right?
Because there's other things you need to
be attending to.
It's not a stable solution for you,
your family,
your society.
It's too one sided.
Yeah,
and you can get pulled down rabbit holes
of all sorts that are one sided pursuits
of meaning,
so it's something we're actually going
to talk about as the later classes
unfold.
The question is how do you stop yourself
from falling prey to a pathologist sense
of meaning and I think one of the
answers to that is don't lie because
what you're hoping is that your nervous
system is sufficiently healthy and well
program so that what it reads out to you
is reliable and if you pathologize your
psyche by either through sins of
omission,
let's say or or outright deception,
you're going warp that internal
structure and it's not going to read out
properly to you and then your sense of
meaning will lead you astray.
So like one of the reasons for speaking
the truth,
I shouldn't say that because you don't
know how to speak the truth,
but you do know how not to lie and it's
a game.
You're playing with yourself.
You can define the damn lies.
No one else has to do that for you.
You,
you,
you try not to utter falsehoods because
you wore your neurological structure by
doing so,
and then it will read out pathologically
and then if you rely on it to guide you,
it will run you right off a cliff.
So that's where there's a moral element
to this is if you're going to rely on
your sense of meaning,
make sure that you don't pollute the
mechanism.
See,
this is.
This is partly why people go to
confession,
right?
Which is,
which is a psychotherapeutic technique.
It's like,
okay,
what stupid miserable wretched things
did I do this week?
Oh,
that's a good thing to,
to make conscious,
right?
Because maybe you cannot do them the
next week and you think,
well,
why would you bother?
It's like,
well,
you're in a ship sailing across the
stormy seas.
If,
if you're,
if you're hacking holes in it with a
pickaxe,
you should probably pay attention to
that before you sink,
so it's a good idea to keep,
to keep what you're doing.
That's stupid in mind so that you can
stop doing it,
and so then you can more and more rely
on yourself and your and your own.
Your own conscience,
let's say,
as a guide to proper action.
You know in the Pinocchio story is that
the conscience was not an unerring guide
for Pinocchio.
It had to learn and so and so.
It's also partly pushing yourself into
new situations and differentiating
yourself so that you get wiser and so
it's courage as well as truth.
That was,
those might be the two.
There's more beauty,
courage,
truth,
you know,
the fundamental virtues.
Why be virtuous?
That's the question,
and so that you can bear the suffering
of life without becoming corrupt,
right?
It's practical.
If there's nothing more practical than
that,
so unless you want misery and people do,
you know it's exciting.
Misery.
So other questions?
All right,
then.
See you next Wednesday.